hi I'm John Carmack I'm the chief
technology officer for oculus I work on
virtual reality I've been challenged
today to talk about one concept at five
levels of increasing complexity so we're
gonna be talking about reality and
virtual reality what the technology
allows us to do today what it may allow
us to do in the future and whether that
should even be our goal to approximate
reality so do you know what virtual
reality is yes it's simple it's vert
it's like a video game except it feels
like you're into video games that's
actually a really good description the
idea is that if you've got a system here
that can make you see whatever we want
you to see then we can make you believe
that you're anywhere else like on top of
a mountain or in a dungeon or under the
ocean or in Minecraft yeah or in
Minecraft when you look at an TV on the
wall there he's showing like a picture
of a mountain or something how can you
tell that it's not just a window and
there's something else behind it because
it always doesn't look quite right if
you have a static picture of a person on
a screen and you move around like this
it's not really changing and it's
interesting those are things that we
have to figure out the ways around it to
fool you in virtual reality we need to
figure out when you look at something in
reality how can you tell whether it's
real or not have you been to a 3d movie
where you put on the little glasses and
um yeah so what they do the trick for
that is if you ever add a theater and
you take up the glasses and you look at
it you'll see it's blurry where there's
actually two pictures that they're
showing at the same time and what those
little glasses do is they like one I see
one picture and the other I see a
different picture so then your eyes can
say oh it looks like I'm seeing right
through the screen or something as
floating out in front of it in the VR
headsets what we do is there's actually
either two screens or one screen split
in half so that it draws a different
picture a completely different picture
for each eye and we make sure that each
eye can only see the picture it intended
to and that's what can make things feel
like they've got this real depth to them
that it's something that you could reach
out and touch and it doesn't feel like a
flat TV screen
[Music]
try and look I look over there and
concentrate on his face over there can
you see me waving my hand without
turning your eyes no all right so at
some point you can probably see it right
now
all right so without moving your eyes
this is kind of hard tell me how many
fingers I'm holding up there's barely
tell hmm and you see that even in like
if you hold out your hand
and you focus on your hand then your
foot would be blurry because there's
that difference there and you can change
between that like you can then focus on
your foot and your hand gets blurry
because your eyes can see different
amounts of detail in different places so
we're hoping in the future that hardware
can be like that where we can make a
display that puts lots of detail right
where you're looking and every time you
look someplace else it moves the detail
over to there so we don't need a render
a hundred times as much as we've got
right now figuring out where you're
looking is a pretty hard problem what we
try to go about this is by taking a
camera and looking at people's eyes and
then try to figure out is the eye
looking over here or up here and we're
working hard on stuff like this right
now so we hopefully can have a virtual
reality that's as detailed and realistic
feeling as the reality that we've
actually got around us but it's gonna be
a long time before we get to I you know
where we can really fool people so do
you have a basic sense of what latency
is yeah so my understanding of what
latency is is it's it's basically the
time delay between the rendering at
different points so it's basically a
delay and it happens in all parts of the
system monitors can be a big one like
you know consumer televisions can often
have 50 milliseconds or more of latency
just in the TV part and then you've got
the processing in the computer and all
of these add up to the total latency the
latency is in my opinion the most
important part of the AR because if you
have that offset your body is no longer
immersed and you get you gain that
motion sickness which can pull a lot of
people out of the experience games that
feel really good they've got that sense
of it happens instantly when you're you
know when you're doing something
it really is a testament to this kind of
technology and the how it's developing
and how over time it's gonna just be
you're gonna be able to pack more pixel
density in this displays and it's gonna
get a lot more immersive like 30 years
ago you had desktop PCs which were you
spent whatever on that but there was
always this idea well you could spend a
million dollars and buy a supercomputer
and it's gonna be a lot faster and
that's not really true today for scalar
processing when you just do one thing
after another okay a high-end
overclocked cooled gaming PC is about
the fastest thing in the world it is
within a very small Delta yeah for some
things you'll get some power from you
IBM power system that might be a little
bit faster but not a whole lot so if I'm
looking at this and saying we need to be
five times faster you know what do you
do you can't just say make each thing
faster you're bait as a developer you're
making a trade-off I can put my effort
into making this more efficient or
making it more fun and more fun usually
wins out for very good reasons so
there's some good judgment and trickery
that goes into the design of things you
can always design a game that will just
not work well I am I mean in the old
days games had to be so precisely
designed and nowadays you've got a ton
more freedom but you really can't just
the hardware old games are running off
and they fit and that's all the days you
could have yeah any crazy idea you know
you could probably make a pretty good
video game which is a wonderful
wonderful thing yeah a lot of freedom
but VR makes you have to give up a
little bit of that freedom you don't
know not do so many crazy things so that
you could wind up having it be as
responsive and high-quality as it needs
to be mm-hmm that's very interesting
you know an interesting topic is what
are the limits to what we can do with
virtual reality where I'm pretty pleased
with what we have today what we can show
people and say virtual reality it's cool
people get an amazing response from it
but we're still clearly a very very long
ways from reality that kind of notes
back to realism in our history and how
realism was response to romanticism and
realism was meant to capture the mundane
everyday lives of you know individuals
and not idealize any of their activities
or any way and I think that that's
really important for virtual Rhianna I
think it's kind of like a rite of
passage for any kind of our technology
to go through mostly in VR we talk about
the display and optics the visual side
of things but we should at least take
off the other senses and haptics is an
interesting thing about virtual reality
really doesn't have that aspect of
touching things you can move your hands
around you could do everything but it's
a disconnected experience because you
know you don't have you know the actual
solidity there and I am pessimistic
about progress and haptics technology
about almost all other areas I'm an
optimist I'm excited about what's coming
up but I don't have any brilliant vision
about how we're going to revolutionize
haptics they make it feel like we're
touching the things in the virtual world
so I've you know tried the demos where
there's like VRLA there's one that has
waves like audio waves I believe that
come up and then you can put your hands
through that and feel the way is
whenever you're supposed to be feeling
bubbles or any kind of force note or
something those are pretty interesting
I've seen some pretty interesting things
that you could do with audios you can
cut down a lot of the storage I guess in
the power that you would need in order
to power huge scene you can just you
know mimic the sounds of those scenes
actually being there and then not
actually building out for example the
professor at USC would have the sound of
a train drive by without a very actually
rendering the sound and you'd feel like
you're deeply immersed in this world
without having to have such an expensive
scene built around you so I think those
are pretty you know significant and that
is one potential quality improvement
that's still on the horizon is when we
do spatialization we use the HRT of the
head relative transfer function to make
it sound like it's in different places
but usually we just use this one kind of
generic here is your average human HRT F
function and it's possible that of
course if you are right in the average
then it's perfect for you but there's
always people off to the extremes that
it does
do a very good job at and there may be
better ways to allow people to sample
their own perfect H RTF which can
improve the audio experiences a lot it
all comes down to all these trade-offs
you know with display and with
resolution it's one of those things
where if people have one bad experience
they kind of out rule everything else is
really difficult to build trust again
with people who haven't done beer before
but it's easy to break all that trust
whether they do it was a huge concern
about that at oculus and the term
internally that went around was
poisoning the well they were very very
concerned I mean for a long time there
was a fight about whether gear VR should
even be done because the worry was that
if we let a product go out like year VR
that didn't have those things that if
somebody saw it and he was bad it made
them sick I made their eyes hurt then
they'd be like I'm never gonna try VR
again I tried at that time and it was
you know it was terrible and there was
legitimate arguments about whether it
was even a good idea to do that and it
turned out that yes it's obviously
better to have all of those things but
you can still do something that's
valuable for the user without it it's
weird being at the beginning of a medium
like this right I'm very excited to see
how filmmakers tackle kind of creating
content in those things especially if
there are experiences of traditional
medium
mostly today I've been talking a lot
about what can we do what's possible we
think might be possible in the next
couple years but really at the
professional level it's more the
question of wisdom of what should we be
doing I mean that's what I think we're
trying to figure out is from artists and
storage or storytelling perspective kind
of what are the things that will make
this meaningfully different from what
we're used to like a television or a
wall and we've been finding a lot of
things that aspects of virtual reality
that very much do that in my opinion
things that allow you to feel presence
first and foremost where you get lost
you have to remind yourself this isn't
actually happening and things that
ultimately allow you to embody other
characters things that you can actually
change your own self-perception and play
with neuroplasticity and teach yourself
things that are bizarre and unique as an
engineer of course I love quantifiable
things I like saying here's my 18
millisecond motion to photon here's my
angular resolution that I'm improving
I'm doing the color space right but you
can look at you know not too far back
where you say we have
DVDs at this amazing resolution but more
people want to watch YouTube videos at
really bad early internet video speeds
where there are things that if you
deliver a value to people then these
objective quantities may not be the most
important thing and well I'm certainly
pushing as hard as we can on lots of
these things that make the experience
better in potentially every way or maybe
just for videos or the different things
I don't think that it's necessary
I've commented that I think usually my
favorite titles on mobile they're fully
synthetic are ones that don't even try
they just go and do like light mapped
flat shaded and I think it's a lovely
aesthetic I think that you don't wind up
fighting all of the aliasing while you
get some other titles and I we're gonna
be high tech with our you know our
specular bump maps with roughness and
you've got aliasing everywhere and you
can't hold framerate and it's all
problematic while some of these that are
clearly you know very synthetic worlds
where I it's nothing but these cartoony
flat shaded things with lighting but
they look and they feel good and you can
buy that you're in that place and we
want to know what's around that monolith
over there we did a project called life
of us which is exactly that mindset
where let's embrace low poly aesthetic
and just simple vertex shading and we
ended up you know realizing you can
embody these two various creatures and
transform yourself and when you do that
with co-presence of another creature
another human
it makes for a totally magical journey
and you don't even think for a second
you actually dismiss the whole idea of
photorealism and embrace that reality
for it is I think it actually helps put
you at ease a little bit the end goal of
reality of course in computer graphics
people have chased photorealistic form
you know for a long time and basically
we've we've achieved it photo realism if
you're willing to throw enough you know
discrete path trace trees and things you
can generate photorealistic views you
understand the light really well of
course it still takes a half hour per
frame like it always has or more to
render the different things so it's an
understood problem and given infinite
computing power I'm we could be doing
that in virtual reality however a point
that I've made to two people in recent
years is that we are running out of
Moore's Law I am
I mean maybe we'll see some wonderful
breakthrough in you know quantum
structures or whatever or bandwidth I
can but yeah but if we just wind wind up
following the path that we're on we're
gonna get double and quadruple but we're
not gonna get 50 times more powerful
than we are right now we will run into
atomic limits on our fabrication so
given that I'm trying to tell people
that start buying back into optimization
start buying back into thinking a little
bit more creatively because you can't
just wait it's not going to get to that
point where it really is fixed to to
those highest degrees just by waiting
for computing to advance if we want this
to be something used by a billion people
then we need it to be lighter cheaper
more comfortable and there's constantly
novel iux innovations like Google Earth
whether that is the kind of elimination
of your periphery as you zoom in and
move and also giving you the user action
to decide where you're going and they're
looking there's a constantly seeing
people coming up with ways to kind of
break from the paradigms of actual
reality and then introduce very well you
know there's tons of opportunities for
the synthetic case where you want to be
able to have your synthetic fantasy
world where everybody is a creature
that's created by the inviter and
simulated reasonably yeah but of course
we've got been you know we still don't
do people well simulated that's a hard
problem we've been beating our heads
against it for a long time I do think
we're making progress and I wouldn't bet
on that being solved in 10 years but
maybe 20 years because it is gonna take
a lot of AI it's gonna take a lot of
machine learning where it's not gonna be
a matter of us dissecting all the micro
expressions that people do it's gonna be
let's take every YouTube video ever made
and run it through some enormous learner
that's going to figure out how to make
people look realistic absolutely there
are these crucial thresholds where you
pass you know technological hurdle and
all of a sudden that unlocks a whole
world of creative potential but I think
to your point very much we need to solve
the actual human and social challenges
and and turn those into opportunities to
figure out how this technology fits into
our lives I'm still believe that the
magics out there and you haven't found
it yet so somebody is going to you know
happen upon the formula I feel like I've
felt the little pockets of math there's
that oh you can imagine the utility by
creating a world or you can imagine the
power of the story that would be told
you in this context and a lot of it I
think is just picking those putting them
together in a meaningful way and then
crafting something that's that's really
bigger than intentional but I've now
been joining with real people in virtual
reality and you I think we also have
different levels of connection like the
audio side is the leaps and bounds above
in terms of the nuance of personality in
humanity so yeah when I hear people
laughing and joking and and you know
really enjoying something soon we'll get
into the word macro gesture land or I
can wave and say you know but when we
get into micro gestures and I'm actually
getting a sense of facial reactions and
other things I think then we'll have a
really incredibly rewarding time
spending spending time with each other
so v4 right now is pretty amazing when
you look at it it's things that you
haven't seen but we are just getting
started the next five years both
technologically and creatively are going
to really take this medium someplace
that you've never imagined
[Music]